Dean Potter is a world-renowned rock
climber known for his record-breaking a
sense whoa
bold Highline walks an extreme bass
jumps ba boom even combines these
talents to use a parachute in lieu of a
rope I love the idea that I can change
the worst possible thing to the best
possible thing dying to flying for the
past year Dean has focused his immense
energy on the art of wingsuit BASE
jumping the wingsuit is basically the
flying squirrel suit your little wings
between your arms and legs that allow
you to slide
everybody kind of fantasizes about it
flying and it's an amazing place in
history right now that man actually has
the skills to pull it off this summer
Dean spent months searching The North
Face of the Eiger in Switzerland for an
exit point higher on the mountain than
anyone had jumped before I've always
been into exploring and searching for
the the next beautiful spa and kind of
at the highest possible point that there
could be a jump on the Eiger I just saw
this beautiful diving board there
I love to find that magical spot you're
just all alone and it's totally quiet up
there
in August 2009 Dean Potter broke a world
record making the longest bass jump ever
achieved it's about five and a half
kilometers of 2000 meter drop I mean
usually base jumps last second so now
I'm closing in on a three minute flight
passing over beautiful Jade hillsides
down to civilization learn more about
Dean's achievements in the December
January issue of National Geographic
adventure magazine and see all his
exploits on the new series for the
NatGeo adventure Channel first descent